as many schools continue remote learning
and arts budgets face
big cuts as you know two grammy
nominated musicians they are stepping up
to the plate to help
black violin is a group they're teaching
kids all around the country to quote
one of their hit songs they're proving
the impossible is possible
that is true manuel bojorquez shares
their story as part of our series of
more perfect union
showing once again that what unites us
as americans is far greater than what
divides us
we can do anything chances are you
haven't heard classical music
that sounds like this
[Music]
you don't need a cello if you can do
that right it's the sound of black
violin
the genre bending duo working to help
students like those attending their old
school
parkway middle in florida follow in
their footsteps
[Music]
what made you guys pick up this
instrument they inspired me
one time i saw them at my elementary
school and i just started freestyling
whatever they usually do and i was like
wow they sound great
all the way up you in the back right
there
black violence kev marcus and will
baptiste grew up in working-class
neighborhoods in fort lauderdale
at first neither had any interest in
playing a string instrument
i wanted to play the saxophone they put
me the wrong class true story
and i was stuck in the class for two
weeks and i just you know after like the
first week
i really started really falling in love
with this instrument i remember will
always after class he would always just
kind of hop around and stuff
and then like you know every now and
then he'll hop around and play like
these chords these diagonal chords on
the piano and then he'll sing brian
mcknight that was his thing
and then eventually like you know like i
kind of started playing and then like
all of
the other people in the in the orchestra
room started kind of trying to
collaborate and that's i think
when it started kind of the beginning
those early orchestra jams blending
hip-hop and classical music
became the hallmark of black violin
sound launching a career that seen them
perform for the obama family
and with the national symphony orchestra
with marcus and baptiste
shattering stereotypes along the way i
mean we're big black guys you know we're
like you know we should be playing
basketball or football like no one ever
expects us to play violin and so when
you do something that you
you're not supposed to do people you can
change the way people see you
yeah music saves us in a lot of ways and
now i think
we pay that forward nice
to pay it forward the duo conducts
workshops for students from low
income backgrounds see there we go
their foundation also provides grants
and financial assistance to aspiring
artists
without the foundation i wouldn't have
been able to pay for juilliard
pre-college
they really enabled me to be able to
have summer lessons and
participate in a summer program without
their funds i
really don't know how that would have
been possible for me
and during the pandemic the two are
hosting virtual events
for students across the nation thank you
really amazing
music i really loved it amazing cannot
describe the type of music i just heard
we're showing representation we're
showing creativity and then they react
that way
it's almost just sort of a just a
reminder of how
important what we do is like i couldn't
go this way do you see yourselves
reflected
in these kids absolutely and that's why
we
wake up in the morning and perform for
these kids because we see ourselves in
these kids and they see
themselves and us to be at this level
being able to do something that you love
and travel the world and
being able to inspire and uplift the
world i mean it's just you know it's a
dream come true for sure
for cbs this morning manuel bajorkas
gosh thank you will and kev i love kevin
i think it was will who said he was put
in the wrong class sometimes you get in
the wrong class and good things happen
there's so much joy in what they do and
you can see how it spreads so easily
you can also see those kids those little
sponges just soaking it all up
absolutely no
nice nice going places as a result of
that exposure too kev said it right best
when you do something you're not
supposed to do people see you
differently and expect
things you're so right about that it's
true nicely done nicely done